et cette guerre en ukraine a également
des conséquences économiques on l'a dit
mais aussi des conséquences sur le monde
du sport notre chroniqueur sport
justement benoît perche est avec nous en
plateau pour l'évoquer bonjour benoît en
bon soir benoît cette guerre en ukraine
donc on l'a dit qui n'est pas sans
impact donc sur monde du sport oui
puisque dès les premières heures de ce
conflit beaucoup de sportifs ont pris la
parole ou la plume pour dénoncer cette
guerre sur leurs réseaux sociaux
sebastian vettel inconcevable d'aller
disputer le grand prix de sotchi pour le
pilote allemand la question ne se pose
plus car depuis bien le promoteur de la
formule 1 annonçait que le grand prix de
russie qui était prévue fin septembre
était annulée chez as on s'est hâté
jeudi de faire disparaître toute mention
d'ouralkali ckoi aura le khalife à une
société russe sponsor principal de
l'écurie américaine et l'avenir de
nikita maghrébine fils d'un dirigeant
d'uralkali qui est également l'un des
deux pilotes as et bien son avenir se
pose cette décision chehat sera prise
cette semaine vendredi matin bien sûr ça
n'a échappé à personne la décision a été
prise et bien de
que la finale de la ligue des champions
ne se disputeraient pas à
saint pétersbourg mai à paris au stade
de france à plus long terme l'uefa qui
va réexaminer son contrat avec gazprom
contrat qui rapporte à l'instance
européenne 40 millions d'euros par an
gazprom qui a disparu du maillot de
schalke nous le firent en allemagne tout
comme aeroflot sur la tunique de
manchester united en première league ou
un club comme chelsea est détenu par
roman abramovitch depuis 2003 le
milliardaire russe a annoncé qu'il
confiait la gestion aux administrateurs
de la fondation caritative du club
champion d'europe en titre des
initiatives vous allez le voir comme ici
avant le coup d'envoi de la rencontre en
allemagne entre le bayern et francfort
et ce message du club stop it poutine
les joueurs des deux équipes unis dans
le rond central sur le plan
international elle la pologne annoncé
qu'elle refusait de se rendre à moscou
le 24 mars pour affronter la russie en
barrages du mondial 2022 une prise de
position soutenue par la star de cette
sélection robert lewandowski le
vainqueur de cette rencontre qui devra
ensuite affronter la suède ou la
république tchèque suédois et tchèques
boycotteront ce match s'il se retrouve
face aux russes des initiatives
individuelles donc on l'a compris benoît
mais que fait que 10 la fifa vient après
à part avoir condamné l'invasion de
l'ukraine l'instance internationale
dirigée par gianni infantino n'a pour
l'heure pris aucune sanction à l'égard
de la russie ce qui n'est pas le cas du
cio qui exhorte les fédérations
internationales sportives à annuler ou
délocaliser tout événement prévu en
russie ou en biélorussie il demande
aussi que les drapeaux de ces deux pays
ne soit pas hissé que leur hymne ne soit
pas jouer la fédération française de
volley a annoncé samedi que l'équipe de
france ne se rendrait pas en russie
c'est le championnat du monde ils
étaient maintenus il doit se dérouler
entre août et septembre la fédération
internationale de judo a suspendu
vladimir poutine de son statut de
président honoraire alors s'il a réussi
à les mises au ban de beaucoup
d'institutions internationales
diplomatique elle est aussi de plus en
plus isolé vous le voyez sur dans le
monde du sport et c'est éminemment
politique entre on sait à quel point le
régime de poutine a pu utiliser ce
levier à des fins de propagande dans le
passé merci beaucoup benoît paire au
chai pour cet éclairage donc sur les
conséquences de cette guerre en ukraine
sur le monde du sport